visitor jeez mr. McKnight see in our the
unforeseen seen as your Amin the J part
the show it's a fan yo per protocol as
per Missy a formal a pauper yield
inverted a jean-pierre stirs spray I
mean you know ease therefore endure
image were commissioned Aron Seely
Kushner moment in a par was erroneous
tormented solely tragedy no Eden tone
wonder who our arsonist then you abuse
my first inter sewer drapery dreads soft
put Marla on Vernon a in from at Sonic
around airports will see two others soft
put sensibilities Ruhr give two-thirds
the function to avoid mala Tasha priests
per burst Eddie porch to each topic
reached home scenario on a par with visa
manganese been dispersed image
founded fire for Tony Moore not moment
emergence and a mother this Bosch was
thought anywhere this booty mean for
when his even upon Frances Sedona Toria
Etsy da-da-da-da-da sandwich corner book
said they put Ceylon missionaries
bashful my prosthetic on a soil matured
young Turkish damage or if M tall subsea
never steerage kind one kami password
unseen touch mine
least I were dead so on the tone the I'm
sure languages shots
may I presume Commission airing to see
me prepare to ship research para from
fighting day they near Fergus Caillou
any bird of opponent aspect see wish
forgiving toward the prospect in
theatres a total at risk management
process it Integra meets their calendars
Baku the permit liver man fire can
daughter no fun to visit the sewerage
fire moon pressing activity not aspect
poor Yoshio transitioners
name she period of been Takeda juror
she was burning as a petition up or
never Charles the fondest were very
primitive human dose precepts a Cuban
Air Service noob power system Arrhenius
awesome authorities
from the cedar of young for Marvin
diamond for my problem in itself coming
for more than Shannon Perrine and Gina
purchaser therefore mostly seen at Part
C their per initiative an erasure dot
activism didn't beam eme took a profound
or do team and then expertise on their
entire pert happily offensive symbol or
under cream in turn on his world that
exponent that Kingdom is war he read
under a to achieve cut through the
proper order
she sinner a sinner fired fresco to para
dude it'sh he percussion organ is a bose
cup chat kibosh the poi for Dorian out
or Italian interior not so fast under me
admin mass system it via a portion that
the stained area under thought nah a
former port buffoon or Harper that
battle system ok proportional allocation
Aaron very near to the foreigner who are
poor resident of a foreigner or
anonymity to the feast just function to
process it in the timid past tragedies
usually ashland or each orphans own
purchases the hint agreement pass miles
the truth now
commission area is spreading here Masada
and if you are asked for you
thank you very much Prime Minister thank
you very much for having me today in
Albania this is the second stop in my
first trip outside the you Member States
for me it was a priority to come here
very early on in the mandate to
reinforce our support for Albania and
also to reinforce the geopolitical
nature of this new commission as you
know for us enlargement and the Western
Balkans is a priority we want to
increase our presence here we want to
have more influence here we want to be
even more important partner for this
region and for this I will be working
very hard and tirelessly with the prime
minister to make this happen we still
consider the report of the previous
Commission on Albania to be valid so we
still consider Albania to be ready to
open accession negotiations and we will
be working to make this reality still
before the Zagreb summit of this main
the Commission will come with a set of
new proposals based on three pillars the
first is going to come already this
month this is going to be a new
methodology when it comes to the
handling of the accession negotiations
we have to understand that the failure
in October to open the accession
negotiations were also related to
concerns on the side of the Member
States and some Member States and we
have to look into very carefully to
these concerns and we are ready to work
to
with our friends here and also our
member states to find a solution that
will create a new opportunity for us to
move forward with the enlargement
process in the methodology we try to
come up with with a new approach that
will be based on four principles four
principles that should be working both
for the accession countries but also for
the Member States first of all the
process would have to be more credible
it has to be more political treatment as
well and it has to be more predictable
and for me it is also a priority to make
it more dynamic so we are putting
together a proposal that will deliver
that the second pillar to me is to be
able to start the accession negotiations
with Albania and North Macedonia this
year still before the Zagreb summit
we're working on this with the prime
minister but also with the Member States
and then the third pillar would be the
Zagreb summit where we hope to come
forward with an economic development
plan for the whole region to be able to
speed up the building of a solid and
resilient economy and to bring these
countries much faster much closer to our
own standards in this context of course
it is crucial to continue with the
reforms that are ongoing already in
Albania today the Prime Minister
announced a new element which I welcome
very much and it is absolute necessity
not only to continue the reforms but
once we have opened up the negotiations
you will see that even more dynamic
reforms are going to be necessary
so that you can reap the benefits of a
more dynamic negotiation methodology so
therefore I welcome the the government's
commitment in that regard we need to
have all political parties in Albania to
help us to make this reality it is clear
that that without the support of all
parties in the Albanian politics it is
not going to be possible to make
progress and I will be reaching out
today also for for the opposition to
help us to make it a success and to use
the opportunity once the accession
negotiations have started I also welcome
the considerable progress that has been
achieved in the justice reform I think
that the vetting process has shown a
major commitment not only that but to
determination to implement the reform
that was decided I also very much
welcomed the agreement of I think
yesterday on the electoral reform this
is a very important milestone as well so
these are all very good news however we
of course still have challenges ahead of
us we still need to do a lot to fight
organized crime corruption we need to
ensure and improve the state of the rule
of law so we and and we need to work on
this together and I hope to count on the
cooperation of all political parties in
that regard when it comes to praising I
also have some good news
I'm sharing with you now which is that
given the the very good performance of
Albania in relation to the use of
pre-accession funds I have been able to
request
from the European Parliament which is
the budgetary authority to to release 28
million euros as a so-called performance
reward which should be with you very
soon
I have positive news from the Parliament
side but still they need to run their
own processes to be able to approve that
but the proposal is already with them
and it should be coming soon
and let me lastly but most importantly
talk a bit about the earthquake and the
donors conference first of all let me
present my condolences to those who have
loved who have lost family and friends
and let me reassure you that we are
standing by Albania and we will continue
to help in whatever we can we will
organize the donors conference in
February together with the Prime
Minister on the 17th of February in
Brussels we're sort of underlined the
president of the Commission will be
hosting and opening the conference we
attach great importance to the donors
conference we will be reaching out to
all UN members but also all the
financial international financial
institutions and international
organizations to come and contribute and
so we plan to contribute with a
significant contribution ourselves we
will also we talked with the Prime
Minister about our announcement on the
15 million euros that this commission
has presented already at its first
college meeting I understand that the
implementation of that contribution has
already started and we will see to it
that it will be
they're very quickly on the ground and
helping people on the ground instantly
from here we are going with the Prime
Minister to do - to visit and to visit
the sites so that I also get my personal
impressions of what has happened and we
will continue today with meetings with
the president also members of the
opposition so I'm reaching out to all
Albania with these messages and Prime
Minister once again
thank you very much for having me thank
you very much for inviting me
[Music]
the mic of the morning
[Music]
as I said I'm I am I'm reaching out to
all Member States and try to convince
them that with this new methodology that
we are about to put in place we should
all be able to agree to open the
negotiations and I'm also transmitting
good news and further progress from
these countries this is why it is very
important that North Macedonia and
Albania meanwhile continues with the
reforms so that we can come to an
agreement still before Zagreb to open
the negotiations from near universal
Church they're a little rapid rate
Marion a bomb a major in every youth or
a church leader many disguting branch on
no machine European leader man
methodology James
[Music]
you sure
verbal mercy upon the earth employers
pillars chassis admission a little man
the rhythm nerve Orion for that may even
a coastal port adopt or that primordius
bashful in methodology ma per statsman
Sierra College seedless Provost et al
Montu mando hot air Sushma porphyria
Francis was the University for civil
issue usually process a branch of
resiliency a legume senators I wish you
commercial mancine not be a pre-heated
more if you saw a television it can
affect my gosh on a proposal Minister
for there's a dia concrete East breeze
Newton dog there in a Mars chrome and
all should melt the vendee vapor
happiness ADA worship Linda Marshall
dinner Macedonian a very old sub
co-founder for Paris a meat eaters a
great bit further north Koch concrete
ears to new moon doggy dairy not at all
kuru murder van Americas was October
Vonda curvature a format that you
authority to adverse dog needs your
concrete the akane-chan concrete probity
methodologies October Vonda you may have
seen that I have already visited Paris
last week I had meetings also with the
Dutch authorities the two member states
with who have expressed concerns back in
October and we have been discussing
these concerns meanwhile I am reaching
out also to the two countries who were
affected by the by the October summit
and I try to look into the progress that
that has been achieved and what could
still be achieved during this period and
very hopeful that with the new
methodology that will rebalance if you
will the accession negotiations both for
the accession countries and for the EU
member states and with with with the
progress still being made in Albania and
North Macedonia we will be able to
change
the political climate I'm very hopeful I
had very positive discussions in Paris
and so did I have with with the Dutch
authorities we're working very very hard
to make it happen here for indeed give
the wounded a press release a toucher
new dog lawrence krauss oratory I wish
in a epic on worst burn discs are megohm
endure read TOA metru in rotational
reform our Posse get a torturer Kohan
became European men nuki boiling
professional young boy whimper Cartman
of an account of Newton so say the
second area or port shown great Cisco
field approaches left for the birth
defect Oh datura purest purpose Maria
loaded to object even $7 on approaches
in the river of young men avoid japonica
ratio Mirta can't pronounce shoe sure
when women calamari
she'll european for the Dutch oven demon
narrower symbol the Avenger so eating
some straight from a summer soon
resultado then the demon a suppressor
provided
[Music]